hello everybody I got a special little
surprise for you my buddies over at
cyndago made a sketch comedy where I am
the narrator to my own horror story
here's a little sneak peek startling
Daniel into a wide-eyed panic the ID
Falls from his shaking hand I still have
it
the abruptness of the distant clanking
and crashing sent Daniel into a stiff
and silent panic unable to say a single
word taking one last look around his
dreaded entrapment he falls to his knees
to rescue his identification from the
van I said taking one last panicked look
around his dreaded in Trotman he falls
to his knees to rescue his
identification from the floor no no no
no all right fine
give me a second all right let's see
here okay all right clearly not
interested in picking up the obviously
important ID card that plays a crucial
role to the plot Daniel decides to stand
around like an idiot he's just waiting
for the evil and to test to find him Oh
let me say something let me say
something
that's it that's all you get to see if
you want to see the full video click
here here here here or here right on my
face practically anywhere and you'll be
taken over to their channel where you
can watch the full video trust me it is
amazing they did an incredible job I'm
really happy to see them they're a very
small channel that's just starting out
but they've got incredible talent so
subscribe to them like the video
favorite it if you think it's worthy and
please share it with your friends
because they deserve it they are really
talented so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye